what is magnus doing with his mouse he
hasn't clicked on any squares he hasn't
clicked on any pieces yet he's about to
give up his queen is that right
oh my god magnus carlsen has just given
up his queen what um he's going to get
three pieces in return but look at this
the black knight i said it was pinned it
cannot move it stepped back capturing a
bishop and then white bishop took a
queen right now it's a crazy imbalance
white has a queen black has a knight and
two bishops in return so actually three
pieces they add up to nine a queen worth
nine it is roughly balanced but when a
queen is on the board it's all about
cane safety and black's king is a clear
target that's just look how
this is just an exercise in dominance
now it's a queen on the board and that's
it game over
magnus carlsen wins the first tiebreak
game and what a game it was impressive
stuff by magnus carlsen with the black
pieces anish geary loses with the white
pieces here he has to win the next blitz
game starting in five minutes a niche
two take this to armageddon magnus with
white pieces in game two we'll only need
a draw and anish is shaking his head was
this just simple
genius play by magnus owen king quite
early in the game he wanted to attack
the black king but he forgot about his
own king and yeah after that magnus
carson once he mobilized his pieces look
how happy he is look at that smile on
the world champion